apple the almost three trillion dollar
company are they about to go all in on
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies well
there's been a lot of speculation there
has been tons of people wondering what
is the software giant going to do
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies are even
smaller than the total market cap of
this company there's over a billion
people that have iphones sitting around
the world rick burton an entrepreneur in
the crypto industry has got a great way
of thinking about it he said that
apple's position on crypto historically
has been neutral to hostile however the
iphone could be the tool that onboards
millions of people to the ecosystem i
tend to agree with rick on this one now
if we go ahead and look at how they
could potentially do this there's a
whole bunch of thoughts one the iphone
which more than one billion people carry
in their pockets for everyday use can
alleviate the problem the first idea is
that the safari browser extension one of
the biggest onboarding tools so far
could actually be integrated with the
ios 15 update that came back in november
that browser extension support along
with the 54 of mobile traffic in america
coming from safari that's an opportunity
for crypto iphone tools and then on top
of that it could also go into the
hardware wallet game the iphone has a
hardware feature called a secure enclave
it's a subsystem on the iphone a1 chip
that stores information and also allows
you to use sensitive applications like
face id and apple pay ios is unable to
directly access the information and if
apple added an encrypted signature known
as an elliptic curve signature algorithm
the iphone could become a secure crypto
hardware wallet to hold private keys and
for digital authentication that would be
pretty interesting and this isn't just
about things in the future that apple
may or may not do remember tim cook owns
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies we've got
this video right here where he talks
about it do you own crypto in any
bitcoin or ethereum would you play
around with this i i do yeah i think
it's reasonable to own it as a as a part
of a diversified portfolio and i'm not
giving anybody uh investment advice by
the way
when when did you get interested in it
i've been interested in it for a while
and uh i've you know been researching it
and and and so forth and so uh i think
it's interesting and not only does tim
cook own bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
but on top of that about two years ago
apple went ahead and created bitcoin
icons they literally went ahead and
designed these exact ones that you could
see right here those bitcoin icons they
were used in devices in the sf symbols
what the hell is apple doing with these
bitcoin icons nobody exactly knows
apple again is almost a three trillion
dollar company one billion people around
the world have an iphone in their pocket
crypto is becoming a global phenomenon
if all of a sudden we awoke the beast
and apple decided that they were gonna
get in the bitcoin and crypto game would
be an absolute game changer it would
drive a massive inflection point it
would accelerate mainstream adoption
and ultimately it would bring incredible
economic prosperity
jobs and opportunity to people around
the world
just a matter of time until apple gets
in the game when they do it and how they
do it is up for debate but eventually
everyone capitulates hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time